I am Kanye West it's my pleasure to
present my five most motivating moments
of all time I'm standing up and I'm
telling you I am Warhol I am the number
one most impactful artist of our
generation I am Shakespeare in the flesh
what is knee Nike Google now who's gonna
be the Medici family and stand up and
let me create more or do you want to
marginalize me till I'm out of my moment
or why don't you empower yourself and
don't need them and do it yourself
ha wait take a few steps back - I got
the answers man you only got the answers
on you you ain't got the answers you
want to get the answers wait I've been
doing this more than you doing we got
you ain't got the answers you ain't got
the answers you ain't been doing the
education bro you ain't been doing an
education you don't have the answers
don't because you're trying to give me
advice about doing you ain't got to ask
you ain't spent 13 million dollars in
your money trying to empower yourself
but I spent hundreds of thousands and
don't put now clothing lines at a
smaller degree all I'm asking you and
there ain't no Ralphs though what's the
name of your clothing line we don't know
exactly and I can lose money on a higher
level two answers I'm asking you for the
answer it's a question why is it that
you can you have money I lost the money
because I did not have the knowledge
that are you doing the right Ronnie so
you don't have the money to do it that's
your answer
you ain't gotta turn up man this ain't
no show man not talking to us a homie
now ain't no homey man because the thing
is the bottom line is man I only fight
you ain't gotta talk you like you ain't
no ain't no homey listen bro you know
hold
ain't gotta be no holdup I'm actually
ain't no holdup I'm matching ain't know
what you mean and ain't no holdup man we
hear talking that civilized people I'm
trying to understand your world because
when I go to your concert I'm curious
about what you're saying I don't know
that's why I'm asking you the questions
well I'm explained to you Oh a bus you
ain't got to turn up on me man a man dog
these mics we could turn all this [ __ ]
off you ain't got to do this it's cool I
love you bro but you ain't gonna turn
them in them
don't try to embarrass us I'm not trying
to embarrass y'all what I'm trying to
say to y'all is this industry of what
I'm trying to get into ain't nobody
never broke down
ain't nobody broke down we all slaves so
I trying to disrespect you on your show
we all slaves I sell my soul yeah I try
to just affect you period let me talk if
you're gonna have me talk we are slaves
we are slaves and y'all experienced
nothing right here but a moment from a
movie out of glory so many people are
just so obvious they don't even realize
that when they box me in or try to
verbally put me in some type of box with
Madonna in a box that they're really
showing their level of ignorance they're
putting themselves in a box and you know
people can write write write all they
want but what are people doing and if
there's anybody that's out there doing
they know how hard it is to actually do
and I'm like a motivation of the doers
if if everything I did failed which it
doesn't it actually succeeds but if
everything I did failed just the fact
that I'm willing to fail is an
inspiration people are so scared to lose
that they don't even try like one thing
that people can't say is they can't say
I'm not trying and I'm not trying my
hardest and I'm not trying to do it the
best way that I know how what little
information I get
I'm not gonna sit inside of a
corporation for 20 years
the time is now the time is now to
express and for people to believe in
themselves the time is now for it to be
okay to be great people in this world
shun people for being great for being a
bright color for standing out but the
time is now to be okay to be the
greatest you
[Applause]
[Applause]
be
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so used to be John Stephens yeah it
was Kanye West who said change to legend
you know the first person actually was a
guy named Jay IV who's also from Chicago
and his a friend of mine and Kanye's and
he's a poet and we working on Kanye's
album and Kanye was having me seeing all
these parts and jiv was just like man
we're gonna have to call you the legend
cuz you know my voice is kind of
old-school I've always had an old soul
and Kanye as I made just call yourself
John Legend and I was like no that's
ridiculous you know of course Kanye's
got a new album called yeezus a big bold
things and you know maybe I'll just roll
with this whole John Legend thing and my
kind of ultimate deciding factor was
let's not not do it out of fear because
because you're afraid to call yourself
oh yeah let's not not do it because
because I'm afraid that it won't work
out like cuz people could laugh at you
if you don't have a good career and
you're going around calling yourself
legend do you think you now live up to
it I think I'm working on it I'm on my
way when this goes online or whatever it
is it really matters and then like
really doesn't matter what matters is
you know the people who are sparked by
it and the people who are like offended
by it it doesn't matter because it's
about motivating the doers and anyone
that wants to sit around and talk
they're doing too much time they've
taken too much time talking about it
instead of getting up off their ass and
following their dreams because I'm here
to follow my dreams you know and help
other people follow their dreams and
inspire people who are dreamers it's
crazy that we live in a world that if
you're super positive and super creative
then it's scary so what does that tell
you about the mentality of most people
if you're scared of like positivity and
creativity thank you guys for watching I
hope you enjoy I said put that together
because I hadn't seen a lot of Chania
recent
and I kind of missed them I love the
fire of the older videos and hopefully
he comes up with some more new stuff
that can inspire and motivate us I love
to know from you guys what do you think
of this video do you have a favorite
Connie moment that you want to link up
in the comments below let me know thank
you guys for watching continue to
believe and whatever your whatever it is
[Music]
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details